oh and by the way this coming weekend
Thursday Friday Saturday at the brain
probe still tickets left so get your
tickets I will be there I'll have some
special guests at the Bray improv
October 27th at the Comedy Store that's
Sunday at the next Sunday at the Comedy
Store not this coming Sunday but next
Sunday I have a benefit charity benefit
I'm gonna have some very big comics on
that venue some surprise guests get your
tickets now live at Comedy Store calm
it's gonna it's for a great cause come
out and laugh we want to sell this bad
boy out
all the money goes all of it goes to
charity none of it goes to any of the
comics alright let's see if we can do
this well chin Chin's got the giggles
today let's just start with that Chin's
got the gigs like I've done like three
reads and four for like you know adds
and chin can't stop laughing and I don't
know what it is let's see if you can get
through this I want to see I'm gonna I'm
gonna talk about woop and woop is
something that he's laughing already
why are you laughing when i say whoop
whoop is a bracelet do you wear the
bracelet ah yeah it's an excellent it's
an excellent product and in comparison
the other sort of wristbands that you
can wear that measure your heart rate
and tell you how much sleep you're
getting and how much recovery you're
getting it can tell you how many
calories you burn it is far and away the
best it's got the most up-to-date
technology
rogon uses it Sakura uses it everybody
that everybody's using it for sober
October Brendon always has it on I've
been remiss I needed because I want to
track my sleep I want to see my friend
uses it and showed me on his iPhone I
was so sold he was showing me like
exactly what kind of sleep he gets it's
crazy it can tell you whether you get
when you're in REM when you're in light
sleep when you're in regular sleep like
deep sleep it's crazy
you can also basically it's got a
five-day battery life too so you don't
have to charge it every day and it's a
it's actually a sleek-looking band it
actually looks pretty cool so it's got
live heart rate monitoring improved eye
it's called pronate band which is you
know but waterproof and the whole thing
and it's it also it's got a sits puts
car what's called a strain coach these
are the software improvements chin is
laughing I broke them I broke them I
knew it I knew it the strain coach gives
you training level recommendations based
on your body's recovery to take the
guesswork out of how hard to push
yourself for optimal training so that's
kind of crazy I don't know how it does
it but it's got this crazy technology so
it's got live heart rate calories live
strain in real time with your phone use
the videos to analyze your performance
or share with a coach on your social
media it's got a heart rate broadcast
connects you to whoop to Bluetooth Low
Energy compatible devices so you can see
your heart rate on the devices you train
on and with so Rupe has provided an
offer to the listeners of $30 off the
first purchase with the code fighter
just go to whoop WH Opie com use the
code fighter at checkout
save $30 to optimize the way you train
there's one thing I truly believe I
think the best supplements on planet
Earth
belong to on it and you know I say that
because I know the owners and I know how
insane they are and more importantly I
know that they take the supplements
themselves I'll tell you what I take
I'll just tell you what I truly believe
in so I don't speak out of ignorance I
take shroom tech sport which i think is
unbelievable I truly believe it's like I
can feel a difference
I take creatine because I've talked to
too many Sciences to say that it's it's
outstanding for your brain and for you
know strength and recovery and all that
I take vitamin d3 spray I take melatonin
sometimes I take I had really bad food
poisoning and I was nauseous for a month
and I took total gut health and that's
been stats been vetted I've talked to
their doctor about how they arrived at
their probiotic protocol and it's insane
those guys don't play around it's
Robocop means come on it's Rogan and
strawberry Marcus they don't they don't
[ __ ] around they take their bodies
pretty damn seriously but I'm telling
you that that
got health cured me it was such a
godsend it was crazy krill oil I also
take that I'm just telling you what I
take okay I don't take out forebrain I
don't take alpha brain instant but I I
know too many people that are very
effective that swear by it so I have to
believe it works so that's my pitch on
the supplements oh by the way to me best
protein powder on the market it's got
whey protein isolate that way a lot of
people are way insensitive are way way
sensitive they don't even know it
sweetened with monk fruit why cuz monk
fruit actually doesn't raise your
glycemic level and it's got digestive
enzymes so to me best by far best
protein powder on the market is the
stuff out of Anand so on it calm slash
fighter for the best nutrients on planet
earth not to mention the fact that got
all kinds of joint oil MCT oil and
everything else they got Himalayan salt
they can always kind of cool foods which
I also use by the way I like their nut
butter I go crazy for that and then they
got you know apparel they've got
excellent workouts online they've got
all the workout equipment you want my
new place is going to have an entire on
it gym
whoa and Will Sasso just came back we'll
take it easy
shut up what alright let's start this
podcast too but first first you're gonna
shut up alright okay man no no no no
first chairs bigger yeah it is if we got
you a big old you to shut up about seven
or eight seconds ago and here's the
other thing I know that on podcasts we
talk yeah that's what podcasting is all
about hi chin okay well I was going well
it's got the giggles today hmm hi how
are you good yeah I'm will will went to
the wrong studio so he's really fine I
told you to shut the [ __ ] up and before
we get into that and we discussed that
with your audience whom you know yeah
love and respect very much yeah yeah so
much so that especially today I almost
feel like you don't deserve them
well I'm asking you for the last time
stop talking we're gonna do a podcast
first here today you and I yeah yeah
okay okay all right I'll tell you what
that is
okay okay no I'm not asking you
questions I'm gonna tell you what it is
today
Bryan Callen huh
you're gonna take a timeout I would ask
you not to speak anymore if it pleases
ya
I mean if we're friends like you say we
are we are friends known each other a
long time
shared a lot of laughs yeah so I'm just
gonna ask you to let me handle this for
a second and what I'm gonna say it is
we're pulling off a podcast first cuz
you're gonna take a timeout Bryan and
this timeout is gonna be different than
any other timeout that you've ever heard
on a podcast sure someone has to leave
during a podcast take a [ __ ] or it's not
the time for the guests to talk whether
it's not what I'm talking about usually
it's one or two people talking so you'd
probably think that in that you're not
talking then I'll be filling that space
no Bryan we're both gonna take your time
and we're gonna think about what we did
to our friend we'll begin
I'm gonna take a timeout from the
timeout and suggest that perhaps you're
not thinking things through and you're
talking again and that's not what a
timeout is any elementary school student
would tell you that so let's just think
about what happened with our friend well
for a little while I don't know about
you but I'm gonna enjoy how comfortable
this new chair is and get the mic right
here and here we go
good so during that time but won't you
share what you thought of okay look that
I want to apologize no don't start with
some [ __ ] apology that's hollow you
just you can't even prove to me that you
know what the [ __ ] you did for I didn't
know that I didn't tell you I just
didn't realize he you didn't know where
the new studio was and you went to the
old one and Playa Vista and then you had
to drive here and it took you about
twenty-five minutes a day about
twenty-five minutes only about four
miles as the crow flies in LA yeah and
you know that for miles as the crow
flies in LA could take anywhere from 15
minutes to two and a half hours through
man yeah so we got kind of lucky yeah
Volo lucky hey I got a question go ahead
what's wrong with you you know just in
general no I got least long I got these
texts from you and I was excited I said
let's do the podcast and then I got I
just got this you go um I go you go
tomorrow is the last step of tea fat Kay
I'm gonna ruin your [ __ ] podcast
Emily and you call me mo here and I go
whoa bro come on man what's that mean
and then you go what does anything mean
and I go I don't know what that means
and then you go how the [ __ ] should I
know I must have been confused and then
I go you up and you go yeah bro
lol and you sent me a picture a video of
a Russian man wrestling a bear it made
its way across the internet today and I
felt like sharing it yeah you sent me a
lot of bear videos meant a lot of bear
related media yeah cuz it's a bear it's
usually a giant bear sometimes like a
picture of a bear and it's just waving
behind a tree yeah right it'll take
phone calls not cast and then alright
and then I get and then I'll be like
alright dude whatever and then I get a
bear ripping into a carcass or killing
an animal yeah
or the how about that polar bear with
the beheaded cow yeah that was a funny
one
yeah and you know what you're saying is
that you're a bear and then you're gonna
do that to me that's what you're saying
with imagery what I'm yeah just the
you're a beheaded cow in a way Bryan the
beheaded cow Callen you kind of has a
ring to it no it doesn't Ryan's the
beheaded
Cal Cal I don't think that hasn't like
that a lot don't think it has a ring to
it you've got a lot of [ __ ] cool
nicknames none as cool as Bryan the
beheaded cow Alan I don't like it I
think if there's anything that your
listeners and your audience and large
could help you with just to further
things along and you know show that you
know what's up you got cool things like
nicknames Bryan the beheaded cow Callen
well I just think it's a little clearly
you know what you could call your next
comedy special what chop [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you and then I get this 4 p.m. cool I go
yeah you go Kay what hold on why are you
reading this cuz I just want to go
through this you go Kay
Shh then I go no don't do that yeah you
go we're gonna enjoy some silence today
I did say no [ __ ] you and you go [ __ ]
you bro I go dude then you go I'm gonna
[ __ ] you up I didn't mean that I said
why and you said shut up I said anyway
either way it's been nothing but [ __ ]
aggression yeah
well that's interesting that I did say
we're gonna share some silence today
yeah wow that's press quite
subconsciously that came out it's
pressure that's what in a way maybe I
manifested this well maybe maybe I was
late today
yeah in a way that wasn't my fault so
that I could just get aggression towards
you what do you think of that well I
think it's insane because we I want I
majored in psychology right no I I don't
know if you went to college I went to
the University in Canada hold on mm-hmm
they what I went to the University of
Canada is there a unit is there such a
thing is Canada I'm sure they have a
website I
website when I was there was sort of
before timber it says colleges and
universities so here we are studying
Canada top universities cities we said
University of Canada what is the best
University and says Canada right there's
nobody in Canada yeah but you said you
went to the University of Kent yeah but
sometimes they just call it Canada for
short
no no because yeah Canada hey where'd
you go to school I was at the camp not
in the library
no I went to the University of Canada
where I majored in psychology man you
are I think you got caught in the line
you lying dude I don't lie that's one of
the Canadian traits we learn in the
Canadian College of connect I said
you're stumbling over your words cuz
everybody down here in the United States
of America is always like oh you
Canadians you don't know anything
ha ha ha oh hey will because I want to
make a little announcement no uh hold on
a second yeah
don't make okay so all right hey hi
Bryan haha is funny I was late because
Bryan did send me one glass and I pulled
in ha and the and the girl there at the
desk was just befuddled at the mention
of the fighter and the kid yeah but it
did make me smile first of all she
probably one you don't know Bryan Callen
in person yeah no and then so I thought
that was funny and then so I don't
really give a [ __ ] yeah you know what I
mean it's alright that I'm it's alright
that I'm you know that you sent me to
the wrong [ __ ] place you know I'm
already I already drove forever from
where I [ __ ] yeah and from so that's not
a big deal and you know what we are good
friends and you know another thing Brian
we've been late to each other [ __ ] for a
long time cuz we're good pass long time
we used to do a podcast together years
ago and I think we had we did we might
do another podcast Kathy and we
mentioned that on the program here in
the 10 minute podcast with our good pal
Chris D'Elia you and I might just do a
podcast together and I wanted to go
through what made me maybe we could
figure out what we're gonna do
yeah but what if your podcast okay yeah
but here's the thing though do
yeah so let's just get it out on the
table and 10-minute podcast we used to
call it peeling the onion yeah get to
that pearly malleable soft you know melt
in your mouth middle middle of the onion
and just be be transparent Brian and I
have been talking about doing a podcast
together but but but you know don't
don't tell everyone every no I just
thought we brainstorm see what should we
what should our podcast be about because
I had some ideas well I mean look can i
bounce some ideas off you yeah and you
won't be shitty no I'm not gonna be
shitty I'm just saying cuz I'm just
bouncing ideas and I don't like when
you're shitty I'm not shitty something
now you're kind of drum roll in a pretty
hard aren't you but you're already doing
shitty now yeah no no I'm not doing
shitty all I'm all I'm all I'm trying to
say is don't don't promise people
because you have a you do have a very
loyal audience and I'll tell you and I
would like to say this on wax here on on
the fighter in the kid when I get
messages from people that say hey bring
back that podcast and do this or do more
that I really appreciate that stuff and
I and I know that there has but there
are people that have listened to the
whole you know tamanna podcast cannon
yeah there's and there's talk about
reviving I've heard online this is
exactly online online people say that
this talk of that gamer that we there's
no rumor there's people saying that
would be fun if you did that yeah that's
a route there's rumor yeah okay call it
rumor call it what are you going to
happen anything could [ __ ] have it
you can have I could get up and plant my
left foot in on the bridge of your nose
and not hang into that oh and not that
ugly a stupid [ __ ] medieval
grandfather clock that you have for some
reason oh why do you have that you don't
come into my studio and start
threatening physical stuff because I'll
tell you something right now yeah well
right now yeah right now right okay you
come at me yeah yeah yeah what's gonna
happen I don't know what's gonna happen
but I do know one thing for sure right
you know for sure that I'm gonna
I'm gonna me don't fall asleep don't do
that mmm-hmm that's very disrespectful
wait look at this if you do you know
what that is what that's me in deep REM
sleep dreaming of you trying to come out
not dreaming of you wait hold on this is
what I look like
hold on when I'm asleep and I'm dream I
see out here I'm gonna show it to you
again
ready this is how I've severe sleep
apnea already
it's nothing then this is me not
breathing for a minute and a half and
then here's the part where I dream of
you ready and then it goes getting
purple no oxygen definitely having a
stroke watch the world record from Will
Sasso two minutes 18 seconds no oxygen
and then more dreaming you get the
picture oh my god so how am I gonna bow
t'what would happen if I came at you I
don't know what would happen will I but
if you come at me
I know one thing 100% for sure right
you'll [ __ ] your pain no you'll [ __ ]
your pill I know how hard you insulting
son of a [ __ ] if you come at me
Wow peace you up amazed at what you see
up is that something ranking okay okay
okay give up yeah finish I mean you give
me a mich me now my oh me me no I'll
meet you halfway
yeah I'll meet you halfway yeah so
that's all I can guarantee that I'll
meet you halfway
Bryan we cool cuz the ground is coming
at you quick right now the grounds
coming at you Craig right and you might
want them you might want to pull your
pulmo what you shoot right your shirt
right pull my pulling rounds coming at
you quick yeah it's coming at me quick
so your mana at this point right now
yeah yeah at this point right now yeah
yeah yes I'm I'm loose right feel good
right so a little hot
yeah right yeah got some caffeine God
okay right yeah little excited and I'm
feeling strong yeah
quick yeah right yeah so you might want
it well my one or what grounds coming at
ya I wanna tell me getting me halfway
are you sure I'm not pulling those shoes
and I'm not pulling I'm you know I'm
Christa Crowley and it's fine it's
coming yeah yeah yeah it's coming real
quick you know I you know what you're
drooling out you [ __ ] drool your
shirt yeah because I'm cuz I'm foaming
at the [ __ ] mouth no cuz you're a bit
headed cow you're [ __ ] him drooling
with the cud and its own tent mill huh
you were trying to suck your own teats
and got beheaded I don't wish you any
ill physically okay so that's why we
can't ever fought all right yep
cuz those eyes cuz you hide them toward
a wall no you know what you know what we
haven't ottawa you'd you you might want
to yeah well I I put on you into an evil
beast from them from an M night
Shyamalan huh I twist your head
completely around separate all your
joints so that your arms and legs at the
knees go backwards and you'd be like
crawling up like on a wall or someone
somehow can or until like that's what
I'm gonna feel like I'm feel light and
magics a so and I'm gonna turn you into
a horror movie villain well until I
counter so anyway we were thinking about
doing a podcast but what I'm gonna say
to you Brian is don't promise these
people anything that you can't deliver
I'm not promising because when and I'm
now I'm really gonna peel the [ __ ]
onion when when it comes down to ten
minute podcast yeah that's three
separate entities and it's a whole it's
pretty hard to get ahold of three people
to do one thing especially when one of
those people is in outer space
that'd be Chris D'Elia I hope he hears
this because he's [ __ ] in outer space
yes he went into outer space sure did
that guy is in
shoes his new chain he wears a new chain
I thought he was kidding
coffee me too yeah I look at Chris
Thalia and I go like this sometimes
right to his face ago I can't believe
I'm friends with you he texted he texted
us a picture of the chain yeah and you
you knew that this was real so as soon
as I was like huh what and then you were
like oh no that's real that's real okay
so anyway getting three people together
is is getting him from outer from off of
Mars yeah in from outer space yeah you
got to pull him by the oxygen tube
that's hooked up to his space helmet
yeah tough case you'll cancel on you
right quick if we're just gonna like
talk about [ __ ] yeah yeah we shouldn't
yeah I don't know that we should share
that outline but a tough but I tell you
what why I [ __ ] it man you know what I'm
bored you know yeah let's do it let's do
it I would love to do another podcast
called Chris is it is in outer space
Chris in outer space yeah that'd be
great
um I was thinking we do a podcast about
hmm dreams like hmm what just like
everybody's got it what does everybody
have what does everybody have yeah
everybody what does everybody have a
mind a soul yeah but what else what do
they have well they have what is every
person [ __ ] has what sentient
existence yeah but they what else they
have everyone carries body [ __ ] eyes
you know a right to be here to be in
this town really not everybody some
people should be killed rights and we
know that okay but what had everybody
just what everybody how was it buddy
yeah everybody just has like you know
just like a life like life inside of
them okay okay you're getting close to
it a life inside of them
not everybody actually so Chris is a
little bit dead behind the ice right it
doesn't have life behind he has I want
Fink off you my dude you know that kind
of stuff right but but but what does
everybody including even Chris have I
don't know huh
a dream wrong yeah you know I mean a
dream I'm gonna this is a bad idea
no but not maybe not maybe the podcast
is about helping people realize their
dreams so we start with like
affirmations like this like like get
amazing with this we're like hey guys
this is the will and Brian show I don't
know what's a good name
maybe dream big podcast big the dream
big podcast and if you guys want it then
really want it and you know we start
with an affirmation like that mmm okay
that's I'm not trying to I'm not trying
to I'm not trying to like you know grind
things to a halt dude but I really am
okay I'm [ __ ] bored okay well it's
not a good idea that no no it's not
because your idea I'm just you know I'm
just bored now yeah I just got bored
well alright just in general though you
know what I mean mice things up no no
it's not your thing Brian it's not your
problem
I just get bored sometimes what are you
doing you in life what do i do I don't
do anything I just stay home go out and
swing a kettlebell er no you know I know
what that is alright yeah we have the
same trainer Nick tells me you're
working hard yeah I'm working really
hard still fat working hard Nick is
loosening up all sorts of parts of me
that I didn't yeah he'll do that yeah
yeah my shoulders [ __ ] let's see now
you're younger than I mean by I think
ten years eight years eight years now my
[ __ ] body is breaking down a little
bit my Maya I had to sprint in my TV
show I'd do a site or do a run yeah and
several times well
that used to be like okay where do I run
to I have to go through a whole process
where not if I'm running I might pull my
[ __ ] Achilles so I got a I got a roll
my feet
I got a do all kind it sucks and then
the next day I get up and oh I I have
trouble walking so I have to warm I have
to [ __ ] warm my feet up before I get
out of bed not get it I got a warm my
[ __ ] feet up before I get out of bed
something happened all right I'm gonna
abandon my my I'm bored bit that you
just [ __ ] dragged out of the air and
stomped but because I'm more curious
about this okay me too man I'm 44 years
old
yeah and I've started rolling you know
when you get the thing on you roll yeah
where you get the lacrosse ball yeah I
only hey I'm 44 years old yeah I've only
just you know played a bunch of contact
sports for the first 20 years yeah and
then and just BIP I never got a massage
never never and then your dad throw it
up wait some in my twenties a bug
crackling Cleo ah this isn't gonna work
in how many years
yes so and yeah and then 20 years later
you're like I can't I can't [ __ ] like
throwing [ __ ] hurts that's right and
everything hurts and then an NIC comes
along and starts doing things there
that's blowing my mind like having me
roll my lat on one of those things and
then my shoulder starts that's what's
[ __ ] crane he says that some parts of
the body are connected to other parts
and I didn't know this at all
yeah so I've just been hauling up you
know weights and [ __ ] really had never
had a head like a couple of massages
yeah but all this is true only just had
my first deep tissue massage in
September what was that like that's it
first in first time is it my first time
having a deep tissue that's crazy why
because you're insecure by your body or
something you [ __ ] [ __ ] man that
would be really inappropriate here oh no
no take it easy you know if you want you
lost weight a lot don't say oh hey you
want to know something funny get a
close-up of this you see this yep that
is a new belly button
okay graduation I got it here mm oh yeah
cuz you had a about this all that you
know what talk about it we're peeling
the onion you know I really honestly I'm
gonna tell you why I'm bored okay but
but I'll start with this yeah yeah so I
lost 200 pounds back in 1999 to 2000 is
that a real number
yeah you lost 200 pounds I was really
really big Brian if you right after you
left MADtv and I joined MADtv if anybody
out there remembers that I call the
golden era of television comedy well I
was about do that okay well don't do
that yeah well bring Gil up when he was
young please but yeah there's some good
yeah well so what are you gonna do will
sass younger younger let's see none of
those are no that's going down keep
going down no that's once I've lost some
weight there oh that's me that's me
eating breakfast out of the Lord mucker
cup can we can we show that that's right
yeah okay that's good yeah I'm eating
I'm eating [ __ ] cereal out of the
Lord mucker Cup that's what we used to
that used to be the richest prize in
sports every year Christmas Bowl but
anyway make a long story short I was 450
pounds and I looked like I was 300 and
then I lost 200 pounds in a year that's
true Wow
yeah it was [ __ ] stupid and I never
talked about that it was pretty weird
yeah and then and then and then I you
know I promptly gained back almost a
hundred but
not promptly I've just been fighting
with that you know yeah yeah that lost
his heart that 60 50 or 60 pounds but
yeah then I lost a bunch of I lost all
the fat in one crazy year of training
didn't do and he didn't have the Lap
Band or any of that I was just out of 24
years old my body took to it like a
[ __ ] I went to the gym two
sometimes three times a day and brought
were you done felcher what kind of
exercise when you're doing it at the
time no he's he's very very successful
in other areas and he this trainer that
I had was an incredible friend and
really helped me what would you say look
what kind of workout were you lifting a
lot just lifting just just the usual
just just just get in the car you in
before or after a session of you know
highly aerobic weightlifting yeah it's
all okay so now we're talking about the
you know whatever if if you've listened
to any of really night talking about my
body
you could fill in the blanks right okay
so if you feel motivated get out there
and you can do it so I did it and I lost
a bunch of weight and I'm still fat but
it's because I gained a bunch of weight
but anyway you know and I can't I gain
and I lose and I'm totally fine talking
about it I don't sound weird right
honestly all [ __ ] aside yeah I don't
think most people think of you as fat
they think of you as big there's a
difference oh he's a big guy gonna be
frank um yeah I'm a big guy with a big
frame and when I was when I was really
big people were just like what do you
what are you three bills high up over
300 right and I in and I go yeah
and then I'm inside I'm like I wish
that's amazing I'm a sumo what are you
weighing right now so anyway the other
thing about that is I so I had to have
two surgeries to remove a bunch of skin
so they take the the I I won't get too
graphic but some things go off down here
right then thing and then they got to
attach this to this or where'd your
belly button go it's in medical waste
somewhere Wow I actually asked my doctor
if he wouldn't mind preserving it and
giving it to me so I could turn it into
a throw pillow with the David
he was gross and he said well one of the
advantages of having me as your surgeon
wherein I am NOT just a plastic surgeon
I'm a you know Ron Ron around this and
that is that all of the all of the where
they call it out the refuse man whatever
anyway gets rid of it for free I guess
when you have like this [ __ ] done by you
know you gotta go through that some you
know wacky facelift doctor they've got
to pay for the pathology anyway so and
then I had to have my chest done who
gives a [ __ ] man so you know why are you
bored because I feel like if we're gonna
do a podcast I want to actually talk I
want to actually share what I think
about how I feel about all sorts of
stuff
I think I'm bored I think I'm bored hmm
yeah I think I'm a lot of people feel
that way yeah yeah yeah I know I do i I
feel like I feel like there's just a lot
of chatter out there and not very well
thought out yeah and that's what I think
about podcasting it's so weird because
we started doing 10-minute podcast in
February of 2012 and that was late kind
of for podcasting podcasts had been
around for what was it like 2008 when
they started like really because that's
when iTunes gruffly I think was probably
before that I'd be really curious to
know and then by the time we did ours
you know we did it for a while you know
I kept going for a while after a you and
Chris had departed because we all
realized that would be you know because
we're all so [ __ ] busy we just
couldn't keep doing it and now it's like
everyone has a [ __ ] podcast yeah and
I do kind of feel like wait a minute I
was doing that with my friends and it
was fun and it wasn't like this [ __ ] now
were you're like well this is just you
know you look whatever I'm not saying
anything that people aren't saying all
the time but it is kind of you know it's
fine it's industry and it's show
business right so as soon as
the enemy I don't know how much you've
covered this sort of thing here on the
fighter and the kid but as soon as as
soon as people who can make the wheels
go around it can make money from
something see that something is
happening that the kids like they
[ __ ] get their [ __ ] mitts in it
and it's debt which is fine mine which
is great which is great there's no III
want to say there's nothing wrong with
that
everyone should [ __ ] do it and and if
you want to do it and any company should
[ __ ] do it and anyone with a [ __ ]
idea that they can fund and grease go
and [ __ ] do it but we started our
[ __ ] just like I hired a consultant two
different times to like learn how to
like upload the [ __ ] and we didn't have
Logan Moy with us or producer for the
first couple years because I was just
you're doing wrong yeah we just suck it
up on the look there's a book called
we're just doing it in the [ __ ] my
house could've done a Brian salsa
Chris's house there's just three guys
[ __ ] doing it there's a book called I
think cult of cult of the amateur look
that out for a second and and it's a I
had him on my old pup my other podcast
makes mental arts and as you know that
passes where I talked to smart people
and you know
yeah the cult of the amateur I've never
been oh you will
but but it's a really good it's a really
good book because yeah his name is
Andrew keen really interesting well it's
called the cult of the amateur and
basically it's like we live in a time
where everybody has access it can
everybody can get what they have to say
out there yeah whether it's music
whether it's comedy whether it's just a
blog whether it's just a point of view
and most of it is horseshit most of it
as amateurs most almost all of it is not
original so so being original and being
someone who has something to say
something entertaining say something
original to say something fun to watch
something that's actually funny actually
insightful actually moving well that
takes that takes a lot of work that
that's that's a skill writer and and
it's a skill that actually has to be
cultivated studied respected that's why
you go to acting school theater school
that's why you study song and dance
that's why you study how
play an instrument there that's why you
study music theory I mean there there is
there is not only criteria criteria for
good art great art great literature
great music versus amateur music shitty
music pop music there is criteria for
the difference between something that is
moving inspiring overwhelming that's why
some movies are [ __ ] amazing and the
other movies are whatever that's why you
hear some songs that's why you can
listen to Zeppelin over and over again
and it's still astonishing but then you
listen to somebody who's really good
like they have a great voice and the
music is there and and it's catchy and
then you listen to it three or four or
five times and for whatever reason
you're over it yeah and and that
difference without quantifying why that
is that is probably in many ways the
difference between pop art pop music and
Zeppelin classic you know whatever the
case we can get into the details of it
but it's not important but what is
important is that as you notice as Bryan
became impassioned about what he was
speaking on yeah he sat like a chimp
that's right and that's a no Punk though
I am i sat like a monk no you sitting
like a Jim you don't call me a [ __ ] your
tears sitting like my muscularity who's
trying to find a way to suck man your
ringing at you you brought this down the
level of you brought this down to the
gutter a chimp who's who's sitting on a
slope rock and thinks maybe now I can
and he pulled out your teeth and he goes
to his balls and he's like if I pull my
balls you know I know that they're
called balls and he starts pulling this
so that is not this is not like going
towards his mouth but then his finger
goes into his [ __ ] and then it goes
wood does it and then this is just the
rest talking about so important in heat
but then you have to start talking about
side I agree with you though Bryan
Callen that's an interesting that's
interesting was the cult of the cult of
the amateur yeah and yeah I'd like to
I'd like to read that but never read a
book
I'm Canadian you [ __ ] but I want to do a
podcast I have the anecdote I think we
have a pie I have an idea and you have
an idea we've been talking about yeah
we've been talking about that would be a
good idea I think yeah and and I just
want things to be genuine with regard to
what you're saying to that I kind of
feel like that voice comes through when
things are genuine great example is Led
Zeppelin there's a band now called Greta
Van Fleet have you heard of them
okay of course you haven't not not only
well after your time also that horrible
taste in music said it hey yeah
horrible taste no no no no listen Bruce
Springsteen and
you make up a lot of dumb song those are
the only two kinds of views I mean here
this path right now let me before you
too before you play that I don't want to
throw these young kids under the bus
because I do think that you know it's
like when I was a young actor I was like
always and not that I'm not right now
yeah yeah I used to just emulate my
idols and I would just kind of pill for
different takes and go this would be
funny here and there but these dudes are
they sound okay look a lot of people out
here already know about this so I'll
keep it short they sound a lot like Led
Zeppelin well they're wearing too many
feathers and a mule it's rock and roll I
know but that's annoying this insight
twice in the middle yes same guy twice
same twice in the middle twice
same two guys on the other very happy
with their haircuts clamors glam rockers
but we got it we can't wear a string
around your head I think I don't think
that's a lot anyway
even though the 70 if you were wearing a
string around your head in the 70s yeah
somebody a kind person would come up
behind you pull it off while you're in a
hurry I probably don't ya go oh that's
where I put my axe yeah that's right um
so this might sound just like stop
talking about what the ones these guys
sound just like Led Zeppelin but it's
okay maybe they'll develop their own
style later but this in my opinion and
maybe let's listen to a little bit it is
exactly what you're talking about to me
there's nothing behind this because it's
not theirs they're all the same guy
they're they're all the same guy yeah
let's see well dudes and their [ __ ]
killer they're incredibly talented any
particular one play a play
it might be awesome no no keep go to
there there go to there there change
there you know and then [ __ ] it how
about yeah highway to first one yeah
yeah yeah come on man let's get serious
no prisoners guys
[Music]
and it's like it's like do you want to
eat I mean I want to lose I'm out here I
write my own words yeah he could listen
to your language listen but let me
finish a goddamn thing that I was saying
even though I know it's taken forever
but you all need 25 minutes because I
went to the wrong building in the wrong
City
um this is kind of what I believe what
you were talking about
sure you can erect all the [ __ ]
equipment and do a goddamn podcast but
why and I think that's why I haven't
done one now it's been around a year and
a half since we stopped doing tamanna
podcast we gave it away in a contest and
a fantastic diamond knee the diamond
ding yeah we well Tommy blotchy Chad
Kultgen and myself who after Brian and
Chris left top writer producers dear
friends of mine very funny guys
Chad Kultgen and Tommy Blodgett came in
first Tommy and then Chad and then it
got into this weird thing and Tommy was
like [ __ ] it man we should just like
pare this down to the only listener who
gets every reference throughout the
entire Canon of the show before us and
then after and then it's just all these
wrestling references just got you
literally it just sounded like mumbo
jumbo if you hadn't listened to it in a
year it made no sense to anybody except
for those listening to every single
episode
and they are our diamond listeners and
then we we wanted to pare it down to
list literally one person who gets you
know every ridiculous reference from
within the podcast and wherever who's
like all of those and and then we gave
it to a guy yeah we had a content that's
there that was when we did Tom Green
yeah me and my hair yeah dude that's you
wonder why every girl likes me
it's yeah that's back when you were
lucky they were like 51 I'm making a
very interesting funny point and look
I'm sunkissed man that's me a little bit
lighter than I am now see your [ __ ]
son now mom and I really feel like I
should take off all my clothes right now
to prove how good I look naked no my
girlfriend will attest to it even Ryan
you've seen me naked look at me with my
shirt off there we're all right yeah
that's the old ham fat or one Studios
that's a half in the bottom of my house
and bright and it looks like Chris has a
jar of pickles and he's just done but he
does have a job he's eaten that looks
like chocolate cake and a jar of pickles
yeah that Chrissy Chris chocolate cake
in a jar well Chris does if it's not in
food you know Creek Krishna and food yes
no no no Chris doesn't eat anything good
he doesn't got a nice restaurant sir
whoa a difference he sits around where
but he'd said [ __ ] different diets
Vons she's a diner guy well that's where
you get a mustard sandwich with a side
of Turkey that's right which is what
he's a mustard sandwich with Weird Al we
had some good times they're doing that
podcast anyway yeah yeah I just kind of
feel like oh yeah and then we gave it to
this dude so anyway look here's how I
feel I feel like if I don't have
anything to say and if I don't think
that there's a reason to do a [ __ ]
podcast it's a hell of a thing to do the
damn to do the damn deal you've been at
it forever now yeah because you
been added straight since before we were
doing time in a podcast yeah we were
dabbling in it
okay Shaboom beat me up if I miss it if
you miss my shop job is the most
disciplined grinder on the planet yeah I
talked to a guy played football with him
and I go shop when he puts his mind to
it and a guy played the pro football for
seven eight years he's a he was on a
radio show in Denver he goes he's a
[ __ ] grinder dude a grinder he's a
grinder you gotta kill that guy yeah and
it's like same thing he looked at me one
time we had Conor McGregor on and he
looked at me and he said we're just
gonna keep doing this
can I go oh just keep doing I went when
do you think he goes what what there's
no end we're doing this twice a week I
got a TV showing us just make time oh
Jesus I mean I was like all right that's
amazing he's amazing he just that's it
well and it takes that kind of [ __ ] to
do one of these [ __ ] things
especially if you're talking as long as
you two guys talk which is so long you
know you what you're saying here I'm
sorry to interrupt you what you're
staying here through all this [ __ ]
is that you're a [ __ ] you're that's my
water sir man I'll do whatever I want
now that's my water shut up shut up
that's from my tap shut up
I drink tap water if you drink tap water
you got probs Los Angeles has some of
the best tap in the [ __ ] cut off
thanks check it out that's something you
can Google I'm telling you how good does
that water taste it's mixed with coffee
right no it's not well get here wash
that out and do the yeah fresh la tap
yeah whatever so you're basically saying
you're bored and you don't know if you
want to do a podcast that's the saying
let's have a real conversation here's
what I'm saying let's have a real
conversation if we ever do a [ __ ]
podcast again I don't know I don't know
I like doing all the bits I like doing
all that [ __ ] I really am looking people
on I think it would be nice to - really
- you know that [ __ ] you know it's
interesting because I just kind of it
really is I look at all these [ __ ]
podcasts and I'm like what is that one
about what is this one about
people interviewing people do you have a
take
is there something interesting to say so
here's here's what I think there's a lot
of information people want so so just
learning like you know how do you
navigate a lot of the world how do you
even know the difference between
Elizabeth Warren and what a beta or arc
or Donald Trump per se mean if you
really get down to of them are Democrats
and ones a Republican what is the
difference
but I wouldn't mind having somebody
who's really smart get on a podcast for
a half hour 45 minutes talk about that
break it down and then you and I we you
and I start with some funny hey man
listen before you go any further
yeah we can get beta or Roark pretty
soon cuz he's gonna drop out any minute
all right dude I hear what you're saying
I hear what you're saying I know that I
know what you're I know kind of what
you're talking about because we've
discussed it well I want to make ideas
accessible I want to make so so so a lot
of times what I think people think is a
lot of ideas and education is not for
them I think it is I need you to focus
yeah I'll focus you're not a good
student so if we're gonna get ideas out
there we're gonna have a guest on oh
excuse me
I went to the University of Canada not
me so not going you ad student is not it
yeah we looked it up you got the
American Internet here it doesn't work
like that [ __ ] this [ __ ] chairs
doesn't fit just like the other one well
what are you supposed to do that yes you
know how much water I cart around what
am I supposed to fill two of these keep
changing the subject is [ __ ] lid ism
work is anyway I don't think that it's
necessary to just do stupid bits the
whole time that real conversations keep
interrupting everything I try to say
with bits yeah you think Elizabeth
Warren's gonna make it out on the side
somebody I think she ain't here to break
things down for us so it's more than
just smart talk we get information into
people's brains who has time to read a
book nobody maybe we get an author on
not me maybe you and I read 30 with
every pod can't even have time to do a
podcast early every time I want to get
smart people million folks who teach
important ideas I want to get those
ideas out of their heads out of their
books and into people's brains I want to
do
dick and fart jokes we're gonna do that
too
you got chocolate in my peanut butter
we're gonna mix ticking fart jokes in
with intelligent talk shut the [ __ ] up
Bryan Callen that's a good name for your
[ __ ] podcast shut the [ __ ] up Bryan
get in the cell first of all I'll do
whatever the [ __ ] I feel like okay first
of all don't say we're gonna do anything
well you're not the Brendan Schaub to my
Brian no no you don't look at me side
I'd like and say we're gonna keep doing
this cuz I'll smack you you just went
into that gym matter leader the natural
leader right what the [ __ ] have you ever
led naturally dominant this is a [ __ ]
disaster you do that one more time I'm
gonna [ __ ] get out of my car of my
seat you even get out of your car seat
did you just say I'm gonna get out of my
car I'm gonna get out of my seat now
you're a nincompoop say one smart thing
right now say one [ __ ] smart I don't
have to all you have to do is rewind and
listen to what I've said to this point
some of the smartest conversation that's
ever happened on the fighter of the kid
that's not true fighter or the kid a
fighter and the kid fighter or the kid
fighter in the kid fight or the kid take
you off my pod can [ __ ] fighters not
even here right now thing that's not
tuned in you could catch the fighter or
the kid say one smart thing okay I'll
say one smart thing give the young
people something look into instead of
candy all you do is dish [ __ ] candy
say one nutritious thing okay here comes
a nutritious they're candy mouth here
comes a nutritious thought guy Kenny you
want me to say you want to yeah I'm
tired of get into a deep deep I can't
live on hard candy parties and I'm not
running is because I yeah if I joined
the Greenies that'll take votes away
from the Democrats all right well maybe
I could run with a Democrat well what
does that mean that but they would never
do that
governor what what do you say well I'm
just saying perhaps I could run with
someone whose are
in the Democratic field that's how you
take out Trump and he's a friend of mine
he's a friend of yours I'm quite fond of
Donald I don't share some of his
policies or know that yeah I live in the
Baja six months out of the year well I
like that you would run against him
because you're taller you're bigger and
small all right you couldn't really you
I as you know I have a thousand gallons
of potable water and in a silo full of
tortillas I didn't know down in the Baja
I didn't know that now own over 300 dogs
most of them are little dogs terriers
why do you want dogs because I surround
myself with dogs and corn and guns okay
why that's my platform that will be one
of my policies which is what seven years
of corn two guns and three small dogs
for everyone for everyone
seven years a corn seven years not used
all right how much seven years of corn
would cost that would bankrupt the
country faster than when the you know
the the the green new deal and I feel
like seven ears of corn or the the
national debt how much how many comets
corn in an ear each ears of corn is an
ear of corn right so that would be right
that would be I see you don't understand
your corn you probably never served in
the military
they've never had to shuck corn in the
mess hall I had that's the difference
between you and I okay but what is that
you you call yourself an American I was
a Navy SEAL how long can you hold your
breath underwater me I can hold no the
the the okay I don't know it's an
idiotic steampunk grandfather clock
behind you looking I can hold my breath
for probably two minutes I can hold my
breath for 17 minutes that seems like a
world record I don't know if that's true
well what why are you calling me a liar
I'm not calling you a liar I probably
think that tower seven fell because it
was compromised during the
at 9/11 terror it to get into FL on its
own okay
minutes later yeah I know that would you
like to run for president with me me
I don't know anybody get me started I
just keep asking people to rally around
me i I don't know the first thing about
running for president well you ran for
governor were governor yeah I kind of
forgot most of that huh yeah yeah yeah
too many cheer shots yeah yeah you're a
big fella
so so what do you say Ventura Cal in
2020 I don't think so I don't have why
not
I'm just not interested in blow what are
you doing what are you busy I don't
think we could win just what
why wouldn't we win yeah because I'm a
comedian I've got skeletons in my closet
men they would find out what a piece of
[ __ ] I had yeah but you'd only be the
vice president
I know but yeah just be like pence I
never go out for dinner with a woman
okay that's all you have to do is the
vice president Christ and their you know
we'll put you in some some shoes with
lifts in them yeah so you get close to
me I'm six foot four and we'll run
against the Donald he's a friend of mine
all right yeah well okay talking about
that's the [ __ ] that's Bill Clinton
say he's down from Donald Trump um my
wife Michelle yeah pretty good right I
can do any president everybody go ahead
uh-huh
[ __ ] man Oh Barack Obama no no no I
already did that go like old go bold
real old George Washington I'm George
Washington I will not tell a lie and
that's exactly what he sounds like
no but you can listen kick lincoln's
yeah you could listen to andrew
jackson's podcast he had
he had George Washington on I'm honest
Abe very good right
I guess so man so you still haven't fun
podcast
no no why do you do this I don't know
how because that Walkman cuz I want to
[ __ ] and spend money see my drink oh
you're coming from the right place if I
stop drinking wine I'd save a lot of
money oh my god
I'm known to spend money on wine because
I got a want and they go you got to get
this cuz it's from 2007 well well well
that's what I mean Brian we can't talk
about [ __ ] wine if we have a podcast
Leap apnea it's the worst so before I
die let's do a pod right before I go a
Jesse Ventura 17 minutes without
breathing while I'm in bed I got I got
ideas okay yeah we don't need to talk
about that we need to talk to your
people we need to entertain your people
well what do you want to talk about I
don't know what the [ __ ] do you want to
talk about why did you know what here's
what we're gonna do what the [ __ ] it you
want to have interesting people yeah on
the [ __ ] show interview me there you
go all right yeah Ryan you can roll with
that here you know view right and make
it good alright don't be a [ __ ]
[ __ ] about this all right before
I do don't you [ __ ] me did you spend
that money don't make a [ __ ] out of me
what was that all right if you send the
money I'll give you more money don't
make a [ __ ] at me all right all right
okay interview me I'm gonna interview
seriously what I do do it good before I
do don't do an ad come see me oh good
bra
Thursday Friday Saturday October 24 25
26 might even come down and do a set
yeah a set of stand-up comedy brand
Prague be there how about that hair has
anybody perhaps is it hey yeah alright
my next guest no justjust we've already
okay just go
I'm not walking in or anything what it's
be like hey okay so we're here with them
and okay hmm
here we go we're doing the pot no not
our necks like I'm sitting here I'm
doing the podcast with you hey man it's
good to be here dude
good we're just talking my next guest
Jesus John Goodman okay I don't I'm not
doing that I don't know how to do my
next guess is Will Sasso you guys know
him or you don't know him because he
does obscure shows in Canada but will
why acting um well you know the colors
that I paint in are our human colors
right and I just from a very young age I
realized that the screen yeah
was the most vibrant palette will you
love this child please you're a good
interviewer we're your parents present
or actually oh you want you want to talk
about my parents yeah I love my parents
I just saw them all right yeah we were
all hanging out if you're a mama's boy
that's not my words that's your friends
I we we've you know you're a mama's boy
gonna tell you yeah are you gonna
suggest to me that I don't love my mama
you love your mom yeah yeah yeah she's
soup no no no no she died clean me
probably she doesn't fit for me no old
Honest Abe with the cinnamon tongue
you're only half Italian okay you don't
get to talk to me like that I'm okay
asking you I'm an Italian person sure
does your love our mother not she her
you what are you half Scottish my
mother's a harmful sin Sicilian yeah
yeah yeah but so I'm a time what's Big
Mike he's Irish bro he's Irish [ __ ] you
got a problem with that Bryan Callen
yeah you got a problem not a big man
brain college gosh that's Scottish
William I'm your uncle Argyle that's
Irish right Sparky Lyle Argyle
the worst was geography there's AG pipes
when they're played when they're not
played but they're played through
someone's mouth yeah now does your mom
or does she not wake you up with
cinnamon toast does she not clean behind
your ears hey you wanna know something
for real passion yeah you want to know a
real thing yeah this is this this goes
right in line with what I was talking
about earlier with regard to losing a
great deal of weight when my mom
couldn't get me out of bed in the
morning every once in a while you know
when I was like a child in elementary
school yeah you were just talking about
this occasionally she would just just
get just make toast with butter just put
it under my face and like like the
cartoon like Bugs Bunny floating down
the hallway cuz there's like the you
know the the delicious
you know fumes you know that's how we
show our love Italians you know mangia
mangia so my god she'd make you bread
with butter and you would that's a
toasted butter yeah I'm sure you're
familiar with it
it's [ __ ] delicious it's impossible
to [ __ ] up toast with butter is some of
the most I brought my little son a very
special loaf of French bread from the
Whole Foods that he loves yeah it's this
organic softest buckle oh yeah and I
brought it to him because I knew he
would that he would I would cut him a
couple of big slices put a bunch of
[ __ ] pasture-raised butter on that
[ __ ] and he wolf sat down yeah and I it
gives me great joy to watch my
eight-year-old eat that bread because I
know how good it is and you know what
Brian what I think there's a theme
that's that's happening here and it's
very clear to see bread and butter you
see what I mean yeah and what we need is
we need we need that podcast that's just
it's just like bread and butter it's
just like home cooking it's not it's not
pretentious like your expensive [ __ ]
wine or even that bullsh I almost
reached across and slapped you while you
were talking about like who gives a [ __ ]
organic bread and pasture or
unpasteurized pasture raised that's
raised but
so what butter isn't master race race
yeah excuse me excuse me no don't
okay is it because the Chi said pardon
because a cow yeah the cow lives on a
pasture yeah not enough Oh feedlot it
doesn't have a factory farm piece of
[ __ ] same [ __ ]
yeah I know what Shh
oh jeez we found something he's
passionate about cows yeah good cows
he's passionate about I milked my cheese
he's passionate about that one please
and this butter yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
right son
you eat cows that are raised on corn
that's why I already mentioned that yeah
yeah ears of corn that's right
not here in the corn or not and the
rumen is they're not they're not corneas
but you're a piece of [ __ ] let me tell
you something I yeah I eat cows are
raised on what just watches what which
is grass which is grass-fed yes let me
tell you something you may you know how
I like is you know how what I can taste
in steak and I don't care if it's a if
it's a $100 you know fifty day aged dry
aged steak and money on in on in a
fantastic restaurant or you know if it's
in the middle of a cheap burger yeah or
some bathhouse yeah yeah here's here's
here's the flavor that I like I want to
know that that cow has been clanging
down a long metal hallway before getting
beheaded okay but don't on its way to my
plate just like Brian the headed cow
Kalen well that's what I want to taste
the terror I want to taste the
confusions I want all that delicious
confused
I'd stand in this pan next Oh headed cow
the headed cow farms that's what I'd
like to start I want to start a beef
outfit called beheaded cow farms our cow
comes to your plate without a head cuz
[ __ ] cows pasture-raised [ __ ] at
butter you'd cause [ __ ] cows butter [ __ ]
cows butter yeah well give me that hey
we made out of your tip milk [ __ ]
butter [ __ ] cows cows bovine milk
Creamery butter this mean by scared
confused cows so mean I like my cows to
be happy right before death and then you
and then and then my dairy cows right
and then you fed this to your child and
swear to god Nate I'm not making this up
this woman dad date she was dairy cow
farmer she had names for all her cows
and the cows got mad cow well no and the
government came in and shot all really
and she was so distraught
and she said yes I all of them my name's
and they were my too and the guy who am
in house goes like this I swear to God
he goes did you watch did you watch he
was so insensitive
I was so angry just did you watch and
she goes no I couldn't watch and I think
oh thank you very much for talking to us
gang and I was like that's [ __ ] great
you are a [ __ ] horrible person watch
they put all her cows to death mm-hmm
and then my buddy told me that when they
slaughtered a cow
they did it in in view of a bull and the
bull was going crazy and I never forgot
that story that bull is trying to
protect its cow you don't kill cows in
front of a bull cuz the Bulls trying to
protect his cows you know that is kind
of [ __ ] up hey man you know what
that's right how does have feelings -
yeah us Rompin stompin homosapiens do a
lot of [ __ ] up things to animals yeah
we do but making one watch the other die
so we can eat it is a little under bigs
pigs have heart attack let me see there
the other pigs being killed I didn't
know that yeah do is yes what they do is
they have Nia but no that's why they
haven't come around a curved chute they
don't know what's coming on it used to
be they would see their their brethren
being killed and they would freak out
and knew what was gonna happen yeah some
of that [ __ ] is awful because there's
not dumb
I think and I don't like that and I
don't like the kwid pigs are crated
Spears here's something were unqualified
to talk about but hey it's a podcast and
everyone is just [ __ ] sharing [ __ ]
like they know what the [ __ ] have I
prefaced this enough by saying I don't
know what I'm saying
go uh but here's my thing I love meat
it's great I've taken I've taken time
off of it before I did two years of just
pescetarian really yeah yeah dude which
is just you know fish and vegetables I
did that for two years once that's the
longest that I've done that oh I'll do
it you grow up us
I'm sorry sir what was that right sorry
nothing keep going yeah but you did you
shared some sort of joke and then you
laughed super and finally like did you
pump your fist oh okay well anyway I was
eating seafood and vegetables mostly one
more time please what were there nothing
that keeps going keep going it's all
good it's all good
yeah what were you saying I avoided most
bottom feeders a shrimp was probably a
little too fatty things like clams and
oysters I didn't have much mostly white
fish white fish and get your period
excuse me friend what did you what did
you make some sort of now what we use
mention of no that's more is that some
of that bro humor saying I just be
walking out loud what's good what are
you talking about I was just telling you
about my eating habits because you
wanted to have a real you so having you
lived on you have it you but then you
said first of all you said listening I
heard you say [ __ ] dress and period I
heard you say that huh I I heard you say
see ya dress and period ways in
menstruation okay I don't know what do
you mean I don't know why I'm talking
well if you want to have a real
conversation having a real conversation
and other times I actually just you know
went vegetarian for a little while but I
felt like I wasn't here you know what is
what hey hey my penis
that was my penis you touch - Brian
sends me a and Chris D'Elia and Marshall
cook pictures of his penis we've seen
that yeah I've seen pictures actually
one of the funniest things you've done
on on text one of the more daring video
I don't know yeah you can say it again
right one day Brian went abroad sends a
text that Chris and her other pal
Marshall cook and he's like hey guys
what's up I'm in Minnesota probably
where you don't know cuz you're always a
Minnesota no no it's a wonderful place
say Brad cuz that's where I'll be this
weekend I'm in Korea I'm in a room in
Brea which I wouldn't be in otome
because I lived nearby so your
suggestion doesn't work he was in a
hotel room and he's like hey guys I'm
just I'm on the road and rah rah rah and
I just want to know Jesus guys there's a
rat in here there's a rat of it and it's
like a selfie video and it's shaking
around he's like I got it I got it
okay I get no I got I got and like for I
was really like what where is this going
and he's I got it yeah see I gotcha
gotcha a little and then he takes the
camera new pants now and he has his his
his bits his squeezed hard huh twisted
around
your fingers and Knuckles he just
grabbed a handful of his self both thing
all of the stuff and he had it wrapped
up and twisted red I got you just up
just a fleshy pink to red yeah
handful and that was very funny Brian
thank you buddy
oh thank you I I have eaten pescetarian
before yeah and and and I love meat
right it's terrific stuff I [ __ ] love
it yeah and I love pig I love pork
yep but I am starting to feel shitty
about the animals that I'm eating it's a
little bit like is the more we learn
yeah learn how bad it is for the [ __ ]
okay wherever you want to see this is
what I'm talking about with the podcast
we're not gonna get into this topic cuz
we don't know enough about it okay
Google what it's doing to the earth okay
great go away come back and now here we
are what would be great is just some of
that plant meat that these [ __ ] get
in there you know and make more of this
fake shoved me that's just what's gonna
make me without a central nervous system
right so they're gonna grow they're
gonna grow meat that's gonna be the best
meat you can get yeah in labs yeah and I
think that'll be the future and I it's a
little bit like this I was talking to my
buddy Jimmy about this the more we learn
I love the game of football I love the
game of football right but the more we
learn about what it does to the brain
and the more we learn about just what it
does to your body and all that we get
here it's in the conversation is the
juice worth the squeeze absolutely in
some cases does everybody get CT v no CT
v the Canadian CT blood but as we about
what it could do to your developing
brain yeah yeah yeah I would imagine as
we in 20 years young kids signing up for
football will not be what it is today
I'll tell you I played football all you
know all the way growing up rah-rah-rah
and I don't think I would let my kids
yeah and I know a lot of pro football
players who say that yeah and their kids
are built for football yeah and they're
like no not soccer
we start running into people maybe yeah
but it's not a good idea as you learn
more it's difficult to kind of go there
might be other sport that's all I'm
saying it's an amazing sport sure it's a
[ __ ] America is better for it that I
do understand how it can shower you a
little bit no and no I hear ya I love
football but it's interesting I think
about the pee-wee [ __ ] like peewee
football I used to play there's this one
kid hmm this kid anyway it doesn't
matter but he had his he had a small his
head was smaller they just didn't have
like a good helmet for him and I just
remember the helmet rattling around on
his [ __ ] head and then him getting
just crunched up by me and some of the
other fashion is or whatever and like
literally be like oh and we were bummed
cuz this is our buddy
yeah but you know and I'm like a big you
know I'm a big [ __ ] kid I'm gonna be
playing football and it's gonna be fine
you know because I'm a big kid but this
kid he shouldn't even be [ __ ] playing
the sport it's a weird thing but it's oh
yeah sorry you were talking about
concussed cows any work yeah it's like
all the all the [ __ ] that that is you
know that stuff that we're sort of
rethinking now and football is actually
a really good example I'm a big I have
always been a big football fan but I got
to tell you past it's been three years
now haven't really been watching what I
got into yeah I mean I don't I can't
exactly pinpoint meaning what it is I
don't know exactly what it is look a lot
of times football and I'll just say it
it's more about the social gathering it
like because my buddies were coming over
for years watching but it's also such a
great game a game of inches and all that
but when you see guys crush each other
yeah it was like oh yeah you go like
this you go I [ __ ] hit but damn that
was a real hit and that rattled is
pregnant yeah now you know that there's
damage being done get those incredible
athletes yeah
man you know our brains aren't anchored
to the inside of our heads tethered like
that of a woodpecker or a ram or a
[ __ ] lion said that though you look
at how big some guys are just built to
run into people Mark Sanchez was out
here let him through Brennan
days ago the quarterback yeah and you
know Mark Sanchez was a quarterback and
when I met him I went I looked at him
next to Brennan and I went you're
roughly the same size right and I go
what are you wake marks just as good
look in here hundred two hundred and one
pound yeah yeah six foot well he's every
bit of six three and he's about 240
right and I went oh you're just big
everywhere yeah yeah and your
quarterback yeah who looks regular size
he looks regular size there yeah but and
and compared as a quarterback and
compared to those other dudes like just
what oh you're six foot eight and you're
380 pounds yeah at under twenty percent
body fat you can run the 40 40-yard dash
and how fast right Oh oh you'll kill
someone
oh yeah oh you'd kill someone oh and you
have a [ __ ] bowling ball in your head
that you can run into other people
I mean it's [ __ ] it's pretty [ __ ]
up yes
so yeah footballs oh hey did we get that
CTV logo up there who had it yeah but
that CTV logo was that what's going on
no don't put it up there yeah CTV I'm a
doctor Canadian television but too bad
he's not good-looking and really nice
guy either the CT there we are that's
what that's what you get does it play
too much football walk off you get CTV
wonder what that was mmm-hmm so yeah
football might not be a good idea eaten
you know but loads of steak might not be
a good idea and I can't wait until farms
are and hopefully everyone can continue
to work at what they do what they do
well Oh Who am I kidding
everyone will be out of work and it'll
all be you know we will have like when
you talk about factory farming people go
bad on I talked to my father-in-law who
was saying he goes he's been in the food
businesses whole life and I was like we
need to go back to family farms and he
said yeah not really yes then what would
happen is you get factory farms I said
what do you mean he goes because some
families do it better than other
families and also do you like do you
like I'm paying for eggs and knowing
that they're going to be roughly 369 a
dozen or do you like going to the store
one day and having them be 369 and then
going to the store two days later and
having them be $13 do you
do you like about that I go what and you
look so the reason that you you can rely
on milk and eggs and protein and grains
being always the same price here is
because we are able to produce them in
mass quantities right so you'd have a
family that was super efficient and
you'd have another farm over there that
just didn't know how to do it right like
in everything in life some people are
better more industrious more strategic
smarter about things more talented at
farming and that family over there for a
thousand reasons maybe and that family
over there they go like this hey you you
guys suck at making eggs we make really
good eggs but I can use that land how
about I buy your land right and take
that over and then there'd be another
family over there and they'd go let's
just buy their land too and they will
give them an offer they can't refuse and
pretty soon you have crafts right right
so yeah so this is just you know a lot
in the capitalist system this will
happen over and over you know if you
want to feed a lot of people you want to
get you have to get food into a lot of
people's stomachs where people die right
and the way you do that cheaply is
sometimes you have to you have to do it
in a massive cereal an organic way yeah
and that's the way a better way to do it
go ahead look yeah we'd have and I say
this knowing that a lot of people don't
have enough food to eat and I also say
this is a fat guy but we you know many
more people would starve if we didn't
have the means to mass-produce food
yes technologies you know when does you
know when do we go like okay this beef
like I'm gonna buy the [ __ ] beef I'll
buy and I'll buy the new shitty beef
yeah like those uh beyond burgers yeah
those things are [ __ ] fantastic
I've never had one oh they're really
good I'm squeamish about them no cuz
they don't seem like they're good for
you
what What's in um beets it's plant
protein it's like plant it's like a
plant that's why me yeah can we look at
the enjoy a few times I would love I'll
eat the [ __ ] you know beef raised in
matrix like [ __ ] pods yeah where it's
just like a gigantic [ __ ] building
with all of them you know so there's
water people tea nice lit expeller press
canola oil refined coconut oil rice
protein another national
it's a lot of processed yeah it's very
process I mean so I'm our I'll just eat
a rest your NOLA oil scares me
yeah that sounds like it's not gonna
come apart in your arteries that might
make my severe sleep apnea worse maybe
are you doing about your happen yeah hey
for real though I think I have sleep
apnea you're gonna work man you know why
I know this why cuz I wake up I go to
sleep in my bed with my girlfriend next
to me and when I wake up she's in
another room I love your girlfriend
because she's a wonderful person and she
cuz you can't sleep through it
so machine Bob yeah I gotta I gotta I
gotta get it I gotta get it cuz my dad
uses it yeah and I like it it's a
game-changer because he's not bad
sleeping yeah I got she she has no word
of a lie has said to me like you didn't
breathe for 30 seconds I've been I think
I don't sleep really yeah yeah well
you're a fat [ __ ] no I got it's taken me
a long time to get up the bravery to say
that because you're always because you
like to it will emotionally do and you
moving you movin you out yeah but you're
a fat [ __ ] no you need to lose weight
you know would be the fastest way what
to lose weight don't do it we'll lose
that 38 pound heavier [ __ ] you it's so
big and it's full of so much [ __ ] no we
talking about to hear what so I think
you need to rethink having a podcast if
you're gonna have nothing to say so you
have something to say get your finger
don't touch me I just happen to be
pointing at your finger off my finger I
just happen to be pointing pointing at
you dude I'm just trying to make up go
and touch my person okay but I'm not
even look at you but I'm not looking uh
[ __ ] touch I'm just trying to make a
point I'm keeping my finger how can
touch me that's I'm not touching
violation I'm not taking your [ __ ]
finger I'm just trying to make a [ __ ]
play it happens to touch your [ __ ]
beer it's because I'm making a point and
my point
oh you're such a coward
oh you're such a farting coward dude oh
this is such a farting guys I'm sorry
brah
chin come back sorry
embarrassing sorry that's what I just
want it okay okay okay okay okay this
one be brave and that's okay
I wanna get ya get ya I get brave I
don't think I don't think you can't
you're a born cap Dearborn you're a born
counter well why are you not learning
how use your fingers oh god I want to
use my fingers Brian everyone's born
with that no you don't mind G colder
fine just wrap your fingers around the
[ __ ] I'm holding it my mom all right I'm
sorry that I outed you is it I'm just
gonna just leave it
alright let's take a breather we started
with some silence ascend that's what all
right first of all you know what the
bottom line is sometimes you need
someone to talk to who knows what you're
going through or at least knows how to
help you navigate that crazy maze that
is your brain because all of us
sometimes feel lost desperate sometimes
full of self-doubt maybe even suicidal
and and that's just a reality of the
world so your friends sometimes don't
that'll help you your friends are like
you get over it go go lift you know
that's what I don't know I'm not a I'm
not a licensed professional but better
help is something that helps you with
this you don't have to go to a therapist
you can do this online you can start
communicating under 24 hours it's not a
crisis line it's not self-help it's a
professional counseling service done
securely online there's a broad range of
expertise and better helps counselor
network and so you can you can really go
there and see what's going on you can
log on into your account anytime and
send a message to your counselor at any
time you can get timely and thoughtful
responses plus you can schedule weekly
video or phone sessions so you won't
ever have to sit in an uncomfortable
waiting room for some reason chin is
laughing so hard right now and I don't
know why but visit better help calm
slash fighter enjoy any over 500,000
people taking charge of their mental
health with the help of an experienced
professional fighter and kid listeners
get 10% off your first month at better
help calm you work on your body work on
your mind so that sounds the best way to
lose weight I've noticed people come to
me as fans come up to me after the show
and stuff and they're like I lost 50
pounds 60 pounds I've been doing the
keto diet because they listen to big
brown and
one reasons that the keto diet is so
effective is because your body is
basically running on fatty acids not
glucose so you eat you know fat protein
you should have some fiber I guess I
don't know the whole keto program but
how do you know when you're in ketosis
how do you know you're actually burning
fatty acids is not glucose well there's
the keto KEYT Oh breath sensor and Keo
premium these are this is the most
accurate consistent and first-ever
user-friendly Bluetooth breathalyzer an
app for sustainable healthy low-carb and
keto eating so you don't have to use a
urine strip or take your blood which
nobody's gonna do now you can just
breathe into a thing to see if you are
in ketosis $99 a month
I'm sorry $99 not a month $99 provides
key level readings as well as an access
to keeps upcoming food products within
the app for only $8 a month users users
can subscribe to keto premium for access
to videos articles recipes restaurant
guides even it's pretty crazy so follow
the heart healthy keto program keto
premium also unlocks the keto code a
searchable database for food and recipes
it allows users to quickly determine an
items compatibility with the keto
program so go to get keto comm / spider
this GE t ke YT o comm / Fido the keto
app is available for both Android and
Apple iPhones to search the App Store
for keto ke why so hard fighter and a
promo code fighter for 20% off your
first purchase get keto dot-com slash
fighter put in promo code fighter for
20% off your first purchase okay so a
woman in China went to go get eyelid
surgery she wanted the double lid look
and she paid $1,800 for it she came out
of the surgery and said that she didn't
like the way it looked and so the doctor
said oh we're sorry you're not satisfied
with what we did we'll give you another
surgery on the house to fix it
shortly after her original surgery they
went into the second and they botched it
again and so now she can't completely
close her eyelids oh and she has to roll
her eyes and look as far back as
possible to sleep oh but she got a
refund look at that great look at that
picture though everybody ready this is
only for people who listen to the latter
part of the 10-minute podcast with all
the wrestling references ready here
check this out you ready this will be
fun rest in peace right Brian now you
know what that is right yeah you know
that that's the Undertaker when he rolls
it says rest in peace hey chin could you
bring up some YouTube footage of a
second old on a second Brian this is the
kind of fun stuff will be doing on our
pot yeah when we put that together we'll
get some bread and some butter and I'll
be really messed things real to me well
that's real right okay guys I mean it's
something that I believe that's seething
over the art form you will rest in peace
right there no no up a bit that's the
one
okay so she's that's her and she did a
very good
Undertaker rest in peace
well I'm sure that's not helpful for her
but all right thanks that's really funny
then I'm gonna put that on the Internet
okay
she had botched eye surgery yeah
Banzai sir rest in peace because the
Undertaker right bright you know the
Undertaker right it's wrestling you like
wrestling
no it's wrestling like real wrestling
yep
real wrestling that's not the Undertaker
it's not real wrestling though okay all
right that was fun
so I so that sucks hey that sucks it's
nice is that what happens with Itakura
died I would sue them for everything
what are they gonna do I'll tell you
what they're gonna do they're gonna have
to grow like you know that I have to
take her earlobes up so you get the kind
of the eyelid surgery that I want no I
don't think so I think the one you want
you want to take a little more skin I
want to take a little skin off the
droopy skin I'm Tina that's good [ __ ]
makes you look like a fighter now but I
am a fighter or the fighter
Podcast fighter no you're not fighting
yeah you hop around a gym mat with guys
you pay you pay them hey I'm a fighter
here's $100 jump around with me for an
hour so I can punch things well mmm
Viator well you got my you know what you
know what kind of you know what kind of
fighter you are the fighter who has a
hundred dollars to give to someone
ground Scott hey would you hold a bag
for me to punch yes I will well how much
that will be $100 you're sucking here it
is pull your chute no [ __ ] wheel
because the walls come
that's me heading right to the ground
like a bomb no I'm not worried I'm not
worried don't call me you got real close
dude well she's current of that before I
[ __ ] [ __ ] hot in here well we did
nothing about the air conditioner okay
so with the legalization of marijuana
there's a lot of THC laced candies
happening in gummies and no I mean [ __ ]
you either our police officers are
warning parents to be very vigilant this
year when having their kids open candy
cuz we don't know who's gonna give away
lace candy but you could as a joke yeah
but I did not know about this story but
I'll tell you this you could get that
[ __ ] into a closed box and nerds no
problem no problem right yeah just drop
some of that some of that one to one THC
CBD tincture the oil in there shake it
up a little bit
I took some CBD oil didn't do anything
for me you gotta take the ship that has
some THC in it okay
sorry to have to tell you you have to do
drugs it's a plant well I tell you once
that maybe I should be a little no yeah
you just gotta take a lot of it Brian
I've taken some some some CBD some very
strong CBT oils and if you do overdo it
you could be a little logy the next
[ __ ] all right next one so dumb
looking guy was in a newspaper yes this
dumb looking guy called in a fake bomb
threat to LSU when they were playing the
University of Florida cuz his best
friend put a very large bet on the game
and he was gonna lose its good friend so
he called in a false bomb threat to LSU
in order to get the game to stop so his
friend when it lose the bet that's a
loyal [ __ ] now that's not a
smart idea it's not a smart idea but I
like these down for his boy to take that
bigger risk I mean yeah that's a loyal
[ __ ] I'd be like dude you're my
I mean he's trying to save his best
friend so I I don't approve don't do
that
of course but I gotta say that's a
[ __ ] dog right there yeah that's a
dog that's a goddamn roll I don't know
what I'm gonna [ __ ] do so like for a
friend I'm gonna lose man I don't have
this kind of money guys I'm gonna take
care of it don't guys dude I'm gonna
take care of it yeah bro how are you
gonna take dude there's a good take care
I put a bomb that's [ __ ] up so is he
gonna be facing a quite a bit of jail
time he's young right now he is in the
process 19 very young which is
unfortunate but yeah he's probably gonna
face a lot of jail time people really
he's 19 hopefully you can't make a bomb
give me that pass looking fast give him
some stuff given my pass and stuff what
are you talking about some stuff but
like he's 19 right yeah see yeah it was
very dumb thing haha thinking about huh
do you think he just thought that maybe
if you star 67 day you wouldn't be able
to trace the call back to him who knows
how he did it he might die he's young
and very impulsive always he's not a
thoughtful kid he's 19 he's 19 two years
ago three years ago he was 16
yeah you know several years from now
when he gets out of jail he'll be 20 to
block this stupid [ __ ] up so other
people don't [ __ ] do it I also look
at this [ __ ] blondie blue-eyed
[ __ ] with the perfectly
rectangle head
you're a [ __ ] racist yeah you [ __ ]
are hey you know what give the kid a
bride you know what give a kid a break
he's just getting his Yaya's all right
hey he's in college so he calls in a
bomb don't make me I'll tell me he's a
good boy no he's he's a fine young man
you know he just messed up a little bit
found his way into some trouble he did
he's wailing Jennings doing the [ __ ]
bumpers on Dukes of Hazzard for yeah
well looks like them Duke boys won't be
heading up that Black Mountain anytime
soon cuz they're racist black man was
just a name for it look I just got to
them Duke boys their names is Duke and
they have a [ __ ] the Confederate flag on
the roof of their costume you figure it
out he's just a good boy calling in a
bomb threat to a building full of a
hundred thousand people ass all just
College Fund I'll come [ __ ] go to
jail you [ __ ] idiot Jesus you're so
much beauty - this is what I'm talking
about man man I want to do a real
podcast like wrestling real man I want
to do wrestling let me Undertaker you
know what I'm saying
Oh Bret the Hitman Hart you know
wrestling go ahead shout-out to Kyle
O'Reilly in the undisputed era all right
we know this [ __ ] Brian I'm not
[ __ ] Brian be quiet you just [ __ ]
leave a [ __ ] I would like to fight you
we got fans another dude oh yeah what's
this guy he seems guy super bad the
movie super bad you guys didn't watch it
no I never actually never saw the
deposits no I have some great film I
didn't see the I was born in well
there's a guy there's a character named
McLovin oh yeah he called McLovin well
this guy was actually at a bar and got
ID'd he was underage and now that
actually this said McLovin on it that's
great
he got a McLovin ID just like it yeah
all right it was and in the movie it was
a Hawaii wasn't it yeah yes this is an
Iowa fictitious ID guess you know what
I'm saying he had a Hawaii eye you
should be given the bud death sentence
she be killed too okay I'm sorry I
didn't realize that crime wasn't on a
curve all right dude everything is just
everything you did all out the same
amount you dole out the same amount of
punishment for everything yeah because
why would you Marxist who's that what
would you say
you said you're a Marxist no said my
friend mark are you a [ __ ] finger and
marks yeah you're a [ __ ] I knew it I
knew it well you know you know why Brian
you know why I would feel the same way
if I were you
why that all crimes should be punishable
with the with the with the same
repercussions yeah you know why you're
sour you're upset yeah you feel that
you've been unjustly prosecuted and you
know why that is why because you're
headed cow
so it's bring me to the next carnival
there's no Seth Rogen responded though
yes he did yes and he What did he say
something about actor you're the kind of
thing is better than [ __ ] day-lewis
hold on no I do not think that said you
think he's better than [ __ ] yeah
well I mean I just feel that if he had a
chance at the material like in the name
of the father of my left foot that
perhaps he triumphs in roles like that
yeah my work here is done he says that's
great I get hey see ya Hollywood people
of good people everybody's out there you
know just give him a little not of the
cab of the tweet that's what I like to
do I peruse the Twitter for stories that
I might find interesting or could even
relate to me in some way and I just
retweet him and I go hey here's looking
at you Internet I've got a broadcast
yeah yeah what do you think we should
call our podcast the sad cow podcast
[ __ ] lots of cows butter let's just call
the podcast [ __ ]
cows butter and then people just be like
what does that mean meow and no one will
listen to it alright is that it MIT if
you want it to be come see me at the
frame October 24 25 26 will sasso
probably come down and hold my [ __ ]
water and then busy and then October
27th we got I got a charity at the
Comedy Store Sunday you should come and
do a little bit there on which or you
should talk to David Greco maybe David
Greco shows up I do a thing where I
dress up is another person into a set of
stand-up comedy it's called Dave Greco I
did it on a minute podcast it's quite
fun having said that I've never really
done all that much real already for this
conversation
you born me before I jobs right now in
order for the night that's medicated on
the other where I just spent a frenzied
punch line or even worse or had some
pantomime like hanging my
with the [ __ ] drinks and you're in
here bravas it's I'm addict I'm at the
collège factory how is that any
different from your factory it's a laugh
or maybe a comedy store that's why we're
gonna laugh cuz you're going into the
comedy store yeah you're going into the
Laugh Factory so we put the pit and then
what comes out ha ha ha it's a laugh
factor all right look you're coming to
dinner I don't they come together and
join I don't make the little left Comedy
Store factory huh and and then and then
they could have more comedy huh because
this farm would be like we are doing
comedy over here better we got Bryan
Callen we got Chris D'Elia and then over
there we're like no they don't so that
it's like the view from over here we got
these guys and then no one go and then a
comedy star goes I tell you what Laugh
Factory we'll buy your [ __ ] comedy
club and then I put them together huh
and then that's how your [ __ ] comedy
proliferates
and then finally there's just some mega
fine Amazon of of comedy clubs just
called comedy place no it's like the
size of a [ __ ] big Kmart and everyone
said there's just like a Doppler effect
from the back you can't even you see the
person hitting the mic on their leg I
think that's other people like should we
laugh now and then like wait here comes
then you can hear it yeah at the back of
the [ __ ] house man I'm telling you
Brian I'm [ __ ] bored dude alright
dude gonna get me out of this if you
[ __ ] want dude alright let's we can
do another podcast if you [ __ ]
alright but we're not gonna do some
[ __ ] retread [ __ ] where we just
[ __ ] interview some guy I was talking
to those more about some [ __ ] that you
and I do you know what that is what
that's just life that's just a
conversation
I know everyone normally mom I love
dolly
but I saw that Dolly Parton has a
podcast oh wait a minute her podcast
should be called why does she have I
love Dolly Parton too but her version of
I will always love you is way better and
you know what I hear she wrote it about
her manager because they were growing
apart and when you listen to it under
those knocking under those you'll
actually cry I'm not putting my finger
in your face
you put my finger in your face I'm just
trying to make a [ __ ] point your
honor every one of their buzzing mama
has a [ __ ] podcast mama's boy
you've got chips uh come on dick yeah my
fingers I just said you're trying to do
dick your [ __ ] face you're a hairy
chimp digit up your ass and then you
double ours and I don't want to do a
podcast either I'm [ __ ] where I'm
don't you [ __ ] come out here and I'll
catch with a [ __ ] I'll take my
[ __ ] clothes off if you want to do a
podcast with me it's got to be like this
it's got to be [ __ ] real we don't
come in with a pre worked out jokes and
[ __ ] like that we don't do any of that
stuff we just [ __ ] Cup know when
[ __ ] come in we talk real we have
real conversation all right about the
undertaker about Bret the Hitman that's
not real about pilo r I don't wanna
shout out the undisputed I want to talk
about that stuff Bobby fish Robert I
don't want wrong Adam Cole Bay Bay it's
not come on
all right guys thanks so much for
listening this is the fighter and a kid
we're out